when from local kid who's under age to
the up-and-coming who gets under play
and I can shoot I relate I can do not
see great welcome to Manila
thank you yeah how could they turn a
fake yeah how could they not see great
with the [ __ ] like you up in
their face hi welcome to the Philippines
sir thank you my friend great to see I'm
literally leaving tonight oh yes
people quit all the time because they're
doing it for the money there's a debate
right now going on Twitter of like how
many years do you have to work until the
hard work until the thing this guy's
like Gary you said you hustled your face
off for ten years thank you for thank
you for allowing me to barge in you guys
didn't walk right back here me you liked
being in the region
yeah
[Music]
coconut water yeah I love coconut water
I don't know who these Joneses are but
once I [ __ ] find them I'm gonna kill
them because the [ __ ] Joneses are
[ __ ] you guys up I don't know who
these [ __ ] Joneses are but they're
bad [ __ ] people the Joneses are bad
bad people and they're and they're
ruining most of your lives and I just
don't give a [ __ ] about the Joneses I
don't know these Joneses are and they
definitely don't have any impact on my
[ __ ] life and somebody Google keeping
up with the Joneses and find out who the
Joneses were funny that that's funny
that that was the name of the show only
difference what you do with it now only
difference what you do with it now like
biggest get left for [ __ ] Krauss 50
digits in the titty cos it's a milky
chance I'm on business cloud and it's
tolling days are your [ __ ] somehow
relate 5-time 5-time not important
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you
I mean we could do this the whole time
[Applause]
the macro is not just having the right
business strategy let me give you a
macro voice is gonna wintry Alexa and
Google and Apple are the adult voice
devices everybody in this room over the
next ten years is gonna gravitate
towards voice devices apps are gonna be
built on top of the voice devices and
the next Spotify and next SoundCloud and
next YouTube and the next Facebook the
next trillion dollar companies will be
voiced apps most of you don't execute is
because other people's opinions about
you matter more than your own about
yourself don't get it confused this is
simple as [ __ ] the phone has one if you
do not have content on LinkedIn Facebook
Twitter YouTube you don't exist do you
understand that you don't [ __ ] exist
if you're not putting out something
today somebody else is you're losing
market share the reason I will never
achieve my goals is my goals are third
place so these are people achieve their
goals is cuz their goals was a number of
money if your goal is an amount of money
you've lost so the reason it's empty is
what you wanted to be a millionaire so
what happens next is gonna make ten
million a year like what a hundred
million italy it's the wrong goals my
biggest goals is to be the most
impactful entrepreneur of this
generation by bringing the most value to
all the entrepreneurs that's gonna take
me my whole life so you need to change
your goal from something that's selfish
to something that's selfless because
then it will take you the rest of your
life
okay if that's your passion give it away
[Applause]
[Applause]
I
[Music]